[Music]  [Music]  the corner over there you really ruining  my story right now you know that got an  issue his movement man  [Music]  we have 15 minutes it's time hit it  [Music]  hello boys  or if I told you I know what happens  when you die  you become a ghost buy more criminal  records  no more office parties rush stupid  weddings best part of being dead  is the freedom  not policies or politics no one touch is  mine  we answer to no one you can take outs  and truly evil people  [Music]  okay  [Music]  these people would declare today none of  us will be remembered it's about to  happen we'll do things honey raise the  better ones right the hell are you  or no one  if they exist they can be made not fire  guests  sorry for yelling welcome to the world's  biggest magnet  [Music]  I don't work I mean I wasn't sure sure  had a suspicion but I got no this is all  so [ __ ] dangerous  you  [Music]